Kitagawa: Hi, my name's
Justin Kitagawa,
and I'm a senior product manager
at GoGrid.
I was also
the lead developer
that helped build
our application "GoGrid."
I'm here today
to show you our application,
and we used GWT
to build it.
"GoGrid" is our
award-winning control panel.
Using "GoGrid,"
you can create,
deploy, and destroy
your infrastructure on demand.
You're able to add
load balancers,
virtual servers, and storage
easily and quickly
with just a mouse.
Our load balancers are F5
hardware-based load balancers.
You can specify
a virtual IP,
which will get multiplexed out
to real IPs.
Our virtual servers
support numerous OSs:
CentOS, Red Hat,
Windows 2003 and 2008.
And coming soon
will be Ubuntu and Debian.
And our cloud storage
is an infinitely-scalable,
mountable, um,
disc offering,
so that you can store your data
permanently and reliably.
We implemented on-hovers
for the various objects,
so that you can see
detailed information
for each
of the objects.
We've also implemented
context menus,
so that with
a right mouse click,
you're able
to get to pertinent actions
for the various objects.
Deleting objects
is just as easy
as creating objects.
And with a couple clicks,
you're able
to destroy your server.
We used GWT
to build our AJAX front end.
We knew that we were going
to be redefining and, uh,
data center automation
with "GoGrid,"
and we wanted
to make sure
that we had a state-of-the-art
control panel to do so.
Inspired by state-of-the-art
AJAX applications,
we wanted to make sure that
we were on the cutting edge.
We wanted to build
a thick client
inside the browser.
GWT has allowed us
to create
many of our own
custom widgets,
so that we are able to get
our own unique look and feel.
But we've also been able
to leverage and utilize,
um, many of the existing
UI constructs
such as, um,
the various panels,
suggests, tree widgets,
so on and so forth.
One thing that's great
about GWT
is it's open source.
So if a widget doesn't look
or feel or act
the way
that we want it to,
we're able to essentially
just copy it and tweak it
as we need it to.
And so we've done that
in numerous occasions as well.
It's very powerful,
and it's increased
our productivity greatly.
Um, essentially,
it's build once,
and then you can
deploy it anywhere.
It'll just work
in the various browsers.
And so that's really facilitated
our testing strategies,
and, um, really opened up
development as well.
We're able to build
a very complex,
rich UI application
quickly and easily.